I'm usually not the biggest fan of elected
officials attacking other elected officials
without offering an alternative, a solution,
a proposal, right?
Like I'm against just one elected official
slamming another for the hell of it.
But I have to tell you there's an exception
to all rules in life are almost all rules.
And I'm thrilled that Bernie Sanders yesterday
decided to rip Mike Pence a new one after
Donald Trump selected him to run the Corona
virus response here in the United States.
Because this is not like many other political
issues, you know, a debt and deficit.
Both sides use it to their advantage.
They use it to um, uh, appear to care about
one thing.
When in reality what they care about is scoring
partisan points.
Debt and deficits are not life and death in
the way that Corona virus response is life
and death.
And indeed we are dealing with something that
is literally about life and death.
And yesterday I told you that the administration,
the Trump administration is completely and
totally unprepared to deal with Corona virus.
I told you yesterday that Donald Trump selecting
Mike Pence to run Corona virus response is
absolutely ludicrous.
Mike Pence is the guy who wanted to pray for
HIV to go away in Indiana when he was governor.
He, uh, at which by the way saw more than
200 people infected with HIV there and Bernie
went right in on him yesterday in a tweet
saying, quote, Trump's plan for the Corona
virus so far, cut winter heating assistance
for the poor, have vice president Pence who
wanted to pray away HIV epidemic, oversee
the response, let X pharma lobbyist Alex Azar
refuse to guarantee affordable vaccines to
all disgusting.
Bernie also tweeted a video of Alex Azar,
who is now, he's no longer a pharma lobbyist.
Now he's the secretary of health and human
services.
We're draining the swamp, right?
Saying that he can't guarantee that if and
when a Corona virus, a vaccine exists, it
will be affordable to all.
Take a look at the video that Bernie also
tweeted out yesterday.
Be affirmed then you're saying it will for
sure be affordable for anyone who needs it.
I'm saying we would.
We would want to ensure that we work to make
it affordable but we can't control that price
because we need the private sector to invest.
The priority is to get vaccines and therapeutics.
Price controls don't get us there to secretary.
There is a case to be made that Corona virus
is going to help make the case for some kind
of single payer public health care.
Everybody has coverage system and that the
case is going to be made very quickly because
rich people are going to understand why it's
important that everyone have care.
As soon as they realize, wait a second, if
all these other people can't afford a vaccine,
the odds that I get Corona virus, the odds
that my kids get it because no vaccine is
100% effective, go way up.
We need a system for everyone to be able to
both afford a vaccine if we ever get one,
but also to be able to get care if they contract
Corona virus.
And to add to my comments yesterday about
Mike Pence barely believing in science like
climate change and somehow being in charge
of Corona virus.
It was pointed out to me, Mike Pence doesn't
even fully believe in evolution.
Viruses evolve and mutate and pens who is
questioned.
Evolution is running the Corona virus response
team.
Pence has done this thing that some religious
rightists like to do well.
They say, listen, we're not saying evolution's
not true, but evolution is just a theory and
it should be taught alongside other theories
like God created everything for example.
And of course this is where they either don't
understand or pretend not to understand that
the way you and I might use the word theory
in colloquial language is very different than
the way that the scientific community uses
the word theory pens, the funded planned Parenthood,
which studies have shown reduces abortions
by giving people access to contraception.
And the only thing I'm left wondering here,
I'm not wondering whether Pence is up to the
task of doing this.
He's not a, I'm not wondering whether Trump
has any idea how to pick the best people.
He doesn't.
What I'm wondering is do you think Trump on
some level suspects that Mike Pence obviously
can't handle running Corona virus response
and Trump is setting Pence up to be the fall
guy if things go sideways, but then if we're
lucky and we avoid disaster, no thanks to
Pence, of course going for that.
Then Trump can say, I told you guys I knew
that I was going to pick the right person.
I picked Mike Pence and he was able to get
it done.
Do you guys think Trump may actually be thinking
along those lines or here's the, is he just
really incompetent and decided to put Mike
Pence in there because he thinks he can actually
handle this?
Let me know what you think